freedom
success is doing what you want when you
want where you want with whom you want
as much as you want
last night i met up with an entrepreneur
friend of mine for the past 10 years
he's been doing the same business and
he's tired of it
he's had success but he needs change he
needs something new his passion just
isn't there anymore
but he has a wife and kids now
responsibilities the next business idea
needs to make money and quickly or he's
going to be out looking for a job
panic sets in
there's so much fear in making a change
that he keeps doing what he's doing
instead of trying something else
it's the smart thing to do
winning ideas
here's what i know about finding winning
ideas
you don't get them be being stressed out
and trying to force them
that's the recipe for failure
it's like going on a first date with
someone and thinking about whether
you're going to marry them or not
chill out
give yourself freedom
your best ideas will come when you give
yourself the freedom to explore
i told my friend not to quit his
business but don't close down other
options either
explore try new things see if you like
them
don't put all this pressure on yourself
to find the next idea and if it doesn't
immediately work out you're quitting it
when your mind is free to think
amazing things will happen
here's a salsa tale
after breaking up with my girlfriend of
five years i decided to pick up salsa
dancing
i loved learning to dance and she hated
it what a perfect time to explore and be
free
i fell in love with it the music the
people the movement everything
little did i know that years later i
would go on to be a salsa instructor dj
events three times a week i'm being an
investor one of north america's largest
salsa dance companies
here's the thing
salsa has given me a great business
opportunity but that's not what i got in
it for
i was just exploring an interest and it
became so much more
i could have just gone to one class and
hated it i moved on to something else
i loved it and it became a natural
extension of what i do
expectations
i went in with complete freedom and no
expectations if i was desperate for a
new business opportunity and it had to
work out immediately
i would never have fallen in love with
salsa
i had no background in it took huge
steps couldn't understand the music i
was learning way too late in life didn't
have time to commit full time and so on
all the odds were against me from a
business point of view
but it became a great business because i
fell in love with it and gave myself the
freedom to explore it
freedom
if you're looking for your next winning
idea the idea that will put you on the
map the one that will give you all the
success money and contribution you're
looking for
stop pressuring yourself
give yourself the freedom to try new
things without the pressure of it being
the next big thing for you
you can't
plan to fall in love with someone you
can't plan to generate a great idea
but you can set yourself up with the
best conditions possible
and it starts with freedom
believe